وبينما يركز الغرب وواشنطا على الحرب في
اوكرانيا تبحث روسيا عن النقاط ضعفه في
بقيه العالم افريقيا منها وليبيا تحديدا
حيث يراها بوتين ارض الفرس وقام جلش
ارسل بوتين المع خبرائه الاقليميين
وعينه سفيرا جديدا لموسكو في طرابلس وهو
احد مستشاري بوتين المقربين في الشرق
الاوسط في قسم تغطيه السياسات بوزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه هذه التحركات الروسيه في
ليبيا تقلق الولايات المتحده والاخيره
ارسلت مسؤولين في الفانتاجون لطرابلس
بجانب زياره ويليام مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه ووفقا
بلومبرغ تفكر واشنطن في اعاده فتح سفارتها
في ليبيا حيث لا تمتلك الولايات المتحده
الان لا قوات ولا وجودا دبلوماسيا والصراع
بين الطرفين جزء كبير من اهدافه هو
النقلبي
[موسيقى]
ورقه النفط هي ساحه لتصفيه الحسابات
السياسيه في ليبيا ومطمع لدول الغربيه في
فبراير 2022 كانت ليبيا تخسر يوميا 60
مليون دولار بسبب الخلاف بين البيبه
وبشاغه كان لابد من ايجاد حلول ووجدت
ليبيا الحل في تقنيه الحقول النبطيه
الذكيه وهي هذه التقنيه ستتيح التحكم في
عمليه الانتاج عن بعد عبر غرفه تحكم مجهزه
بالكامل تسمح بالوصول الى البيانات
التشغيليه الحيه ومراقبه النتائج الالات
الصناعيه في الموقع ستعمل مع البرامج
واجهزه الاستشعار لتوفير البيانات وتحديد
المشاكل والاعطال والتي كانت تقتضي في
السابق زيارات ميدانيه
لناخذ مثالا هناك خزانات بها زيوت ثقيله
صعبه الاستخراج لذا لجات بعض الشركات
لتطوير تقنيات لتعزيز الانتاج مثل اداه
البيانات والتي تجعل وتجمع مليون
معلومه كل دقيقتين من عشره الاف بئر وبنيه
تحتيه محيطه هذه الاداه توفر مؤشرات
رئيسيه عن الابار وحاله الخزان ترسلها
لغرف التحكم وبالتالي القرار افضل والكلفه
اقل حتى الوقت المستغرق ما كان يحدث في
يومين يتم الان في الساعه او ساعتين هذه
التقنيه ستساعد ايضا في استكشاف ابار
نفطيه جديده خلال مده قصيره عبر تقديم
بيانات عن الغاز والنفط الى غرفه التحكم
لتحديد جوده النفط
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات